on the floor of a room in donald trump's
florida resort these are we're told some
of the us government's most classified
documents
laid out by fbi officers as they carried
out the raid on mar-a-lago three weeks
ago
the image has been redacted to hide some
of the pages it shows some documents in
sleeves clearly defining their
classification status
the image is a central part of an
extraordinary new court filing released
by the department of justice overnight
remember the decision to raid the
private home of a former u.s president
was huge
prosecutors officials at the department
of justice the attorney general they all
know just how explosive this could be it
has enraged donald trump and his many
supporters and democrats too have argued
that it is in the public interest to
understand why the raid took place
and so over 36 pages this is the
prosecutor's justification they claimed
that documents were likely concealed and
removed from a storage room at the
resort
efforts were made to obstruct the
government investigation
some documents it's claimed were found
in desks in mr trump's own office among
the documents we're told was information
so sensitive that some of the fbi
officers required additional clearances
before they were permitted to look at
them
mr trump can we have a word sir can we
have a word sir mr trump's defense has
varied but central is his claim now that
he declassified the documents yet
investigators say he didn't assert that
claim throughout the year-long effort to
recover them on his own social media
site he offered this
terrible the way the fbi during the raid
of mar-a-lago threw documents
haphazardly all over the floor perhaps
pretending it was me that did it and
then started taking pictures of them for
the public to see thought they wanted
them kept secret luckily i declassified
john bolton was once trump's national
security advisor
with a former president you have to
acknowledge the reality and you may not
like it but it is a reality that he's a
very high profile figure
and if the justice department decides to
proceed here it better be more than
certain
uh that it can prove its case if it if
it goes after trump or his associates
it better be very sure it's going to win
in for it
it's hard to see where this case goes
next but it's clear already that beyond
any legal implications for mr trump the
impact on politics in a nation so split
could be profound mark stone sky news in
washington